In 1810, a live burial happened in France.
She was a beautiful girl from a good family called Victorine Lafourcade...
...and was loved by a poor Frenchman named Julien Bossuet.
However, because he was poor, she decided not to marry him.
Instead, she married Monsieur Renelle.
After a few unhappy years of marriage, she died.
She was buried in a grave in her home village.
Julien Bossuet was alone and sad.
He had never forgotten his deep love for Victorine.
He went to the village, planning to cut off a lock of her hair.
He quietly dug up the body.
As he was cutting the hair,...
...Victorine suddenly opened her eyes, waking from her unconscious state.
She had been buried alive!
Once more, she loved Bossuet. And this time, she wanted to stay with him.
She did not let her husband know she was alive.
Julien and Victorine lived together happily until they were old.